My doctor is going to put me on a phone call that includes Rig Veer and I had a couple
questions.
I know that at least some programs on the right are anti-viral.
I don't know if the program you get for me includes anything anti-viral or not.
And since Rig Veer is a virus based, I was wondering if the right could potentially adversely
impact the Rig Veer's effectiveness.
I would say yes it could, but I will say that I've never put viral programs in anybody's
overnight in any cancer patients overnight.
So the person came to me and they had live disease and multiple infections and things
like that.
I made a virus program in their overnight, but I've never with the cancer patients.
So we don't have to worry about that.
Is there anything I should otherwise do or not do to optimize the potential benefit?
Just runny your right frequencies on the cancer program is going to help any other therapy
attack the cancer better.
So just run with the right frequencies is going to be your best bet as much as you possibly
do.
So the state of good news, the PET scan, all these shows cancer are those two lumps in my left
axillary area.
Don't wear it else.
Just that way.
That's very good news.
I think that they are lumps that live notes not sure, but very glad it's only those small areas.
I'm sure they're going to take care of that.
That's radiation or surgery quickly, I hope, and we'll be pretty spreading that.